mira 18 de febrero y tienes 18 minutos
nomás ramón 18 minutos pacos y hoy
pienso y hace 30 años que cumplí 18 años
brutal 18 y ahora estaba intentando
pensar en mis 18 años y me pongo en
cannes a buscar fotos mías de 18 años
que no la he traído dios como íbamos
vestido así en los 80s impresionante
digo no lo enseño pero pensando en los
18 estaba a punto de entrar en la
universidad nadie me dijo que el mundo
necesita gente que ame lo que hace y
dice derecho que ni lo amaba ni lo he
hecho nunca sano ejercido
en cambio que el santo más y además la
universidad de más creo que me dejó poca
huella ni tatuaje ni cicatrices pasó por
mí
muy poco
pero pensando en los 18 intentando hacer
memoria de qué pasaba en mi vida en esa
época yo sí amo tantas cosas y muy
disfrutan amo muchas cosas y amo el cine
y me pongo a mirar las películas de ese
año para recordar mis 18 y resulta que
ganó un premio ir a la película año de
memorias de áfrica como a cambio la cosa
pero que el mismo año en 1985 se estrena
regreso al futuro así que cuando
veníamos a hablar del futuro digo
perfecto ramón porque para mirar al
futuro para hacer tener perspectiva hay
que hacer retrospectiva hay que hacer
memoria
entonces dije por perfecto esas dos y
fijaros y es curioso que además regreso
al futuro estaba nominada a los oscar
como mejor guión como si el futuro se
pudiera guionizar y además estaba
nominada también la mejor canción que se
llamaba canción the power of love el
poder del amor y yo amo también
muchísimo la música y me gusta mucho
pero claro que la música la escuchaba en
esta época así como el boli bic como
vosotros algunos nos hagáis los jóvenes
escuchaba la música en estas cintas de
cassette y ese año la canción que él o
peto que ganó el grammy a la mejor
canción sabéis cuál era we are the world
we are the chieftains
se guarde sí sí esa misma bueno pues we
are the world me gusta porque hoy el
mundo ha cambiado el mundo es otro el
mundo es tuyo el mundo es nuestro para
para mí es que el mundo va a paso
agigantado rápido es difícil de entender
es muy complejo y además difícil de
interpretar a mi me maravilla es en este
cambio fijaros la música ha cambiado el
cine ha cambiado pero creo que la
educación ha cambiado poquísimo es más
si volviera a lo mejor hoy a una clase
de derecho creáis que sería muy
diferente a la mía de hace 30 años
y entonces creo que lo que está
ocurriendo ahora es que la información
va rapidísima el tiempo sigue su curso y
el conocimiento se está quedando clac
paradito
yo creo que estamos mucha información
por eso y hay que hacerlo las cosas
completamente diferentes mirar para mí
es muy complejo que la educación además
y complejo y paradójico que la educación
haya cambiado tampoco porque para mí
aprender siempre es cambiar si yo no
cambio en mi manera de enfocar las cosas
sino cambio mi manera de hacer las cosas
o si no cambio mi comportamiento no he
aprendido para mí aprender es siempre
cambiar entonces la educación porque ha
cambiado tampoco soy yo digo pero porque
cambia tampoco
me sorprende sigue siendo muy
tradicional y yo ambición o que haya
cambios porque para que haya un mejor
futuro tiene que haber una mejor
educación eso es el futuro por eso
cuando pienso en la educación que yo me
gusta soy docente porque yo amo muchas
cosas y una de las que amo es aprender
amo a aprender y además amar y aprender
son dos verbos que tienes tú que querer
tú tienes que querer amar y querer
aprender no te lo puede imponer nadie me
encanta y precisamente porque vamos
aprender estoy convencido que amo
enseñar llevo ya 25 años he hecho muchas
cosas pero de las que más he seguido
haciendo durante toda mi trayectoria es
compartir conocimiento enseñar que a mí
ya no me interesa enseñar yo no venga
enseñar nada vengo a que otros aprendan
como yo les digo a los alumnos muchas
veces a mí me da igual lo que yo cuente
lo interesante lo que vosotros aprendáis
eso es lo que va a hacer grande por eso
creo que las clases hoy deberían de ser
otras para mí las aulas son esto sea
diferente con diferente tipo de personas
cada uno con sus expectativas sus
anhelos sus conocimientos previos
sus sueños
distinto pero además creo que todavía
necesita avanzar más la educación porque
seguimos poniendo está silla que son
todas iguales los veis pero sé que aquí
cada uno de su padre y de su madre
además y siguen poniendo mirándola a
alguien como si yo fuese un mero
receptor de la información a ver que me
va a contar este y yo creo que en las
aulas la educación debería de haber más
sillas de está para que la gente
construya su silla porque para mí
aprender es construir tu propio
conocimiento eso es aprender y yo de
paso ya de receptores de que la gente se
siente y que ponga su manito me gusta
esto no me gusta no necesitamos más
implicación necesito una palabra que amo
ahora también que es caótico los
sistemas caóticos caos y orden así me
gustan las clases
tiene que haber caos porque el caos es
inherente a la libertad a la autonomía a
la confianza y tiene que haber orden
porque tiene que haber un único objetivo
tiene que haber propósitos pero necesito
que sea mucho más caótica necesito
espacios educativos en los que haya
muchísimos en los que se experimenten en
los que tengamos a descubrir
a reconocernos ya descubrir cosas de
nosotros mismos también por supuesto y
además a generar conocimientos a
conectar eso es un aula conectar con
otras personas por eso qué pasa hoy en
día que la mayoría de los alumnos le
preguntan y lo que se quieren es ir
tan aburridos es que se aburren el que
le pregunta y sé que yo me aburro ramón
es que hay una crisis hay muchas crisis
pero una para mí de la más importante es
la crisis de sentido en la educación la
gente va a estudiar por un título no sé
para qué dice esto pero quiero yo
digo porque te hace falta el título dice
ya presionó vendrían más que no hace
falta por eso yo digo por favor no me
aburra mira a para mí aburrirse
es una cosa súper personal una elección
yo me burlo pero cuando me dé la gana yo
no soporto que me ocurra nadie
este paso es que me levanto y me voy
entonces no quiero que me aburran y yo
me niego a aburrir a nadie me niego a
aburrir la educación no puede ser
aburrida jamás para mí es el espacio más
pleno para hacer más cosas por eso hay
un problema ahora mismo en la educación
que digo que estamos aquí muchas de la
educación también está también bailar y
muchos de los profesores están con este
rito antiguo así como bailando este para
la sociedad del siglo 21 y del futuro
digo pero día mía es que hay falta de
sintonía con el alumnado es que no
conectamos no conectamos con ellos no
estamos en la actualidad para mí la
conexión con ellos es hablar en un
lenguaje que nos permita conectar
interactuar por eso mucha de la
educación actualmente es esta y yo
necesito meterle más ritmito necesito
esto
es el mismo paso lo veis es el mismo
paso clac solo que el apuesto siglo 21
sencillo verdad pero no estamos todavía
bailando como si fuéramos los chavales
de baile que está haciendo se aburren
claro por eso tengo claro que hoy muchas
de las clases son bla bla bla me cuentas
de cuenta la meta idm aburre igualmente
menos hablar más escuchar y sobre todo
algo que es lo que yo quería compartir y
más
ojo que te dice que más hombre que me
maravillé yo quiero para mí para
aprender me hacen falta o o y sabéis qué
pasa que estamos viendo la capacidad de
sorprender a villa no me sorprende casi
nada vemos la tele dije bueno estás
robando que tan sorprende nada sabes nos
sorprendemos tan pocas cosas que estamos
perdiendo la capacidad principal para
aprender que es sorprenderte porque
cuando hay sorpresa hay curiosidad
cuando hay complicidad hay deseo porque
hay estímulo hay voluntad de saber y por
tanto hay acción por tanto haber motivos
y se va a aprender es que para mí
sorprender es la primera pieza por eso
yo vengo con una palabra que he
inventado yo hoy que es sorprendi za je
me encanta el abrigo que patenta antes
que me la quite
yo creo más ahora en la necesidad que
haya sorprendida g y fijaros soy sí
porque para aprender hay que
sorprenderse es la única manera ya para
comenzar como estímulo y fijaros si voy
al diccionario
yo tengo eso sí mucho día el diccionario
de la real academia de la lengua tengo
esas cosillas y dice sorprender es viene
del francés y viene sur prender esa y
prender me encanta porque para mí es eso
hay que aprender a la gente la tienes
que agarrar a mí me tienen que informar
que mover sabe me tienes que [ __ ] y
fijaros que el verbo aprender acaba
aprender sorprender emprender comprender
todos emprender pero hay algunos
profesores que también utilizan uno
reprender
pero fijaros el diccionario dice tres
acepciones que es pillar desprevenidos
conmover suspender o maravillar con algo
imprevisto raro o incomprensible y
descubrir lo que alguien ocultaba o
disimulaba me gusta son tres acepciones
dice para que pillar desprevenidos hay
que conmover y hay que descubrir pero yo
como leo me diccionario pero me gusta
luego hacer las cosas mías voy a decir
los tres roles para el futuro de lo que
debe de ser un buen sistema educativo y
para mí tiene que ser 33 papeles tú
tienes que empujar yo soy un empujador
soy un donante y soy un agitador os lo
cuento rapidito hoy el sistema está
basado en aprobar la gente aprobar y yo
le digo a los alumnos menos aprobar y
más a probar qué es lo que se viene
cuando se aprende tú vienes a probar a
probar y a sorprenderte de lo que eres
capaz de hacer y de quién eres capaz de
llegar a ser eso es probar y oiga lo
bueno tú qué viene a probar por mí está
probado vete ya digo yo pensaba que tú
venías a aprender y por tanto a pesar
que venías a probar a probar cosas eso
es aprender retar
y entonces claro sistema educativo nos
está obligando a aprobar nada más y no a
probar es bueno verdad
pero también fijar pero claro no
probamos porque tenemos miedo y dice
apollinaire acerquen sea el borde
no podemos tenemos miedo acerquen sal
bordes no podemos los que haremos
acerquen sal bordes y se acercaron y él
los empujó y volaron me encanta yo a los
alumnos que tiran pulgadas y que yo no
tengo nada y eso te quiero un poco para
que te tires sabes y hay gente que vuela
hasta que lo intenta por lo menos lo
intenta pero bueno sobre todo hay que
tirarse porque cuando uno se tira
se moja es aprender tirarte arriesgarte
y cuando te tiras hay veces que te
aparece un tiburón
que no te ha salido y te ha pegado tres
bocados yo llevo una carta de bocado o
lo enseña
pero llevo bocado porque no te ha salido
pero hay veces que te tiras y aparece
una sirena que dice que arte que bien
pero walt disney
afortunadamente congelado nos hizo creer
que todo iba a ser la vida sirena y no
vida mía hace falta sirena pero también
hay muchos tiburones la vida hay
tiburones pero claro yo digo las sirenas
están allí para para controlar eso está
estupendo vale
pero claro muchas que cuando hablan lo
que se tienen dicen no no no yo digo
pongais grande no pongáis grande no que
me encanta porque es tener una palabra
que también existe en el diccionario que
es tener voluntad no lenta es lo
contrario a voluntad es el acto de no
querer y alguien te digo tú no quieres
yo no puedo hacer más nada cuando
quieras te espero
entonces yo a muchos no les pongo no le
pongas la una w
le digo now hazlo ahora así que este es
el reloj que tiene que haber en las
universidades los colegios que ahora es
las naguas now
que ahora las no menos no a la hora
sabe claro
pero ese es el primer rol empujador el
segundo donante donante a mí tú me
tienes ya que conmover como decía el
diccionario conmover y no nunca me ha
gustado la presión de la sangre la letra
con sangre entra que dice hoy la letra
con sangre entra
la letra entra cuando le pone sangre que
esos distintos
y para mí es una cuestión de actitud la
docencia actitud de los docentes de los
profesores de los maestros me gusta
mucho la palabra maestro y claro para mí
es un ejercicio de regar sangre de
llevar sangre a borbotones
pero que yo pincho a mucha gente como yo
le digo que te pincho actividad mía y me
sale agua sí de limón
que no tiene sangre gorda [ __ ] sangre
entonces me gusta la actitud el tener
esa pasión digo yo que quiero saber más
de lo que le gusta este porque ésta me
está flipando me agarra y odios que
quiero saber por eso creo que es un
ejercicio de que te riegue la sangre por
tu cuerpo y que a mí me tiene que tocar
aquí aquí y aquí si no no me interesa me
tiene que mover me tiene que hacer
pensar me tiene que conmover porque me
tiene que emocionar y me tiene que tocar
aquí me tiene que remover
provocar buenísimo mover con mover y
remover vale es que si no lo estaba
muchas veces tan ideas hacen falta ideas
pero me tiene que tocar y me tiene que
provocar y un soporte que me diga que se
haga aburrido
sabéis muchos alumnos es que recuenta el
ramón sabe qué pasa que yo antón el aula
y en el 85% de las clases ya sé lo que
va a pasar es flipante salió como
podemos consentirlo o como dice un
compañero la universidad había un
profesor
yo llevo 20 año aquí ramón y yo digo no
vida mía tú llevas 1 fotocopia por 19
porque yo siempre he hecho siempre lo
mismo
lo que me lleva 20 llevaba unos juegos
de amor 19 por eso hace falta regar hace
falta transmite transfusión y problema
que muchas de las educación actual es
esta está anestesiando
y yo no quiero un anestesista quiero
donantes de sangre
y el tercer rol empujador donante y el
tercero es agitador remover lo que decía
del remover y hace falta esto estas
herramientas que hay que llevar para
educar porque yo muchas veces los
alumnos mira ojo tened cuidado que está
escribiendo el huevo tales como un
chorreón del huevo sabéis me explico
y digo que es un peligro te estoy viendo
y hay profesores educados sistema
educativo que lo que estamos haciendo en
vez de agitar el juego lo que estamos
llevando es pan rallado y lo estamos
convirtiendo en empanada
[Risas]
es tan claro que todo porque hay gente
buenísima con unos talentos
espectaculares sólo hace falta la
tercera figura de un buen rol del siglo
21 de un buen rol de un docente que es
agitar los un batir batir los huevos
batir y debatir eso es una clase de
batir a hablar porque se aprende
conversando eso es aprender y no
escuchando uno que viene
[Risas]
conversando se aprende conversando
entonces yo digo que hay que batir los
huevos mucho hay gente a la que hace
falta mucho y viene con el huevo yo
arreando chorreando mal por eso cuando
uno debate y cuando hay un buen debate
los huevos los hay de diferentes colores
hay tanta variedad tantas alternativas
que para mí es lo que hace interesante
la educación no es tu verdad es todas
las opciones que hay
así que esas son para mí los tres roles
empujador donante y batidora o agitador
y se agitó yo digo hay un máster que
hace falta que echo de menos el máster
en el arte de observar
paso de los masters casi la universidad
de bradford malísimos y doy clases los
másteres
en el arte de observar de contemplar de
maravilla arte de unidad de inspirarte
eso es para mí un máster de aprender a
mirar
y yo dice la universidad te enseñan toda
la vida que no copie y no copia copia
todo lo que pueda yo soy mucho de copiar
y de robar es lo que tengo
lo que sí es que copiamos una barbaridad
de cosas pues que no copian nadie nada
soy todos muy originales pues confiamos
copiamos y odio copia pero copia del
bueno ese es tu arte copia del bueno
copia del bueno coge sus ideas a las
tuya a la estudiante realizada y llévala
donde tú quieras para mí sólo
interesante me da igual donde traigan
las ideas por eso se muy observador
mira para todas partes y tenga la
ventaja de que puede haber de pronto
serendipia que es una palabra también
queda incluyó adicionar en el último año
y la última edición serendipia que es el
hallazgo afortunado de manera inesperada
cuando miras llegan las cosas de forma
inesperada como el futuro que es
inesperado y nos está esperando detrás
de esta puerta detrás de esta puerta que
hay que abrir porque cuando uno abre
aparecerán las estrellas fugaces los
sueños
así que lo mejor está aún por llegar yo
solo tengo una cosa que yo no me gusta
la frase de la vida te sorprenderá que
el futuro de sorprenda yo quiero
sorprender al futuro yo quiero
sorprender a la vida quiero sorprenderme
a mí y quiero sorprender a otros así que
muchas gracias y eso era todo
gracias
[Música]